القوات الاوكرانيه استعاده بلده بلاغو
ديتنيه الواقعه الشماليه ضخمه وانسحاب
القوات الروسيه منها هذا ونشرت القوات
الاوكرانيه صورا قالت انها لجنود يرفعون
العلم الاوكراني في البلده واشارت الى
انها ستنشر صورا
في وقت لاحق
كما قالت القوات الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تراجعت بحدود 15 كيلومترا بعد
تفجير سدك خوفك فيرسون جنوبي بلاده اكانت
القوات الاوكرانيه قد قالت انها قصفت
مواقع عسكريه روسيه واسقطت اربع طائرات
روسيه مسيره خلال المعارك في خرسون بينما
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
بدات نقل وحدات من النخبه من خرسون الى
تحديدا من قوه البحريه والقوات المحموله
جوا وقالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
تدمير سد كخوفكا لمنع هجوم من جانب القوات
الاوكرانيه فيرسون لتضييق الجغرافيا
المحتمله للاعمال النشطه للقوه الاوكرانيه